- [Justine] Today, we are
waiting for a surprise
from Nintendo and I
have absolutely no idea
what it is, they wouldn't tell me.
They said bring some friends,
so I've got my friends.
I've got Ed.
I've got Jenna.
There's Matt's computer.
- He's getting a haircut.
- [Justine] What do you see?
- I don't see anything.
- There's a big van.
- Yeah.
- Big, big van.
- Are we having a party?
- Well, hopefully there's
friends in that van.
- Yeah, I hope so.
- Do you want me to go investigate?
Maybe they want you to come out.
- [Ed] Wait a minute.
- Hence the text.
- Should I come outside?
- Do you want me to go
investigate what it is?
- [Justine] No.
- Do we? Do I?
- Oh dude! (laughing)
- It's exactly what I said it was.
(laughing)
- [Jenna] It's killing you, huh?
- [Justine] What?
Oh my gosh, I'm so nervous.
(laughing)
(gasping)
- Are you ready?
- [Jenna] Oh Matty.
- I think so.
- [Jenna] Matty is not
gonna be so thrilled
about what's happening right now.
- [Justine] Matty come here honey.
- [Ed] Matty.
- Should I put him up in the bathroom?
- Go in the bathroom.
- He's not gonna like it.
- Oh no.
- Okay I'm closing my eyes.
(laughs)
- [Jenna] Oh gosh!
- Oh hello.
(laughs)
- Tell me when I can open them.
- [Jenna] You can open 'em.
(electronic laser)
(techno music)
- Mario's in my house!
- Oh my!
(giggling)
- We brought you a present!
- Oh my gosh, hi, how are you?
I'll give you a hug.
Thanks for coming!
Oh my gosh this is incredible.
- Oh man.
- Wow!
- Mario's also in shock.
(laughs)
- [Justine] I've got to open it up.
- [Ed] Oh yeah there ya go.
- [Justine] Mario do you
want to watch it cut open?
Come on over! Yay!
Oh boy!
(laughing)
More balloons, oh my goodness!
(gasping)
Guys look!
This is so cute!
A princess tiara?
This is incredible.
- [Ed] Perfect.
- Trophies?
- That's incredible.
- Oh man we're having
a tournament tonight.
Oh my goodness little flags, yes!
Oh this is gonna be great,
guys we're having a Mario party today.
Here's a crown for you Jenn.
- [Jenna] Thank you.
- This is like a Mario Kart
party in a box, essentially.
Wow, oh and these have mustaches too?
- [Jenna] I wonder what
Matty thinks about Mario?
- This is incredible.
Oh yeah I had to put
the dog in the bathroom.
Let's see what he thinks about Mario.
What is that Matty?
- It's a friend.
- Is this your friend Matty?
- [Jenna] He's like, I have no idea.
- [Women] He's so excited.
- [Ed] Pretty excited.
- [Jenna] Can we get a picture with Mario?
- Yes gotta get a picture with Mario.
- [Jenna] Okay.
Yay.
Alright ready?
One, two, three.
I'll just take a bunch.
- Guys this is by far the
most incredible surprise ever.
Mario is here playing on my couch!
We're playing Mario Kart with Mario.
Wow wow wow, this is so cool.
I think Mario has to go home because he's
got to go, he's got a big day.
He's got the launch of Mario Kart 8.
So we'll see you later Mario.
Which that means now it's me,
Jenna, and Ed versus battle.
- [Ed] Oh yeah battle, we'll play battle.
- [Justine] Thanks for coming Mario, yay.
- Alright guys we are going to be
playing some Mario Kart 8 right now.
Mario just left and Matt
you just missed Mario.
- I know
- Just missed him.
- I'm very disappointed about it.
- So here, I'm playing
the blue controller,
Matt's playing with the two,
Jenna's playing with the two blue,
you're playing with the half.
- [Ed] Mmm-hmm.
- So I guess let's roll.
Matt and I have been playing and ah,
he beat me like 16 games in a row.
- [Matt] 16 races in a row.
- [Justine] Oh I think I'm
happy with our choices.
Alright what are we going to play first?
What do you guys want to play?
- I'm up for whatever, what-ev-a.
- Should we do a nice
little, I like this one.
Uh, Ed do you have a preference?
- Anything that has Shy Guy in it.
- Moo Moo Meadows?
So I'm top left, Matt.
- Oh I'm good It's basically, I can steer.
That was really strange.
- Oh God.
- I got dizzy so I don't know.
I'm comin' for you Mr. Blump.
Oh, ah what's up?
- Blump, oh what's up?
- I'm used to hearing it.
- I got inked, I can't see a thing.
- Okay I lost, oh my god there's a cow.
Oh my goodness.
- I can't see anything.
- Moo moo.
- Moo moo who, who's in first place?
- Ed.
- What?
- Haven't played Mario Kart in a year.
- I haven't played in a long time.
- And you're playing sideways controller.
- Since Justine's birthday.
- I know.
- Two to three years ago.
- Is that three birthdays ago?
- That's the last time that I played yeah.
- That's when this game came out.
- You were so much younger then.
- Oh, I was 21.
- Classic Mario Kart.
- Yo Matt, what's up over there homie?
- I just had to make sure I won, sorry.
- Oh, you're a pig.
You're a actual pig.
- I had to, I'm sorry.
- God, I could, slap you.
- I can't lose, my
reputation is on the line.
(groaning)
- At least you don't have much to lose.
- What did you get?
(laughing)
- Boy oh boy.
- Oh wow I'm going backwards!
Well I pressed the wrong button, my bad.
- I didn't know you could go backwards.
- Yeah, me either well
guess what you can do?
- [Jenna And Justine]
You can go backwards.
- I was pressing the uh, oh--
- Why can you?
- The more you know.
- Because you get stuck on the wall.
I go backwards quite
often when I hit walls.
- I'm never backwards.
- Really?
- Yep, items with the Joy-Con sideways.
New to me but I'm learning.
- Well that's good
because you like learning.
- That's all I do.
- All I do is, oh my gosh,
all I do is learn learn
learn no matter what.
(group groaning)
- Whoever just lightninged just
saved me so much, thank you.
- You did I was comin for you.
- Saved you?
- Yeah I got saved by that
because there was a red shell
on my butt.
- Butt.
And it slowed everybody down and I
didn't get hit by a red shell anymore.
Alright well eat it.
- Well, I basically haven't used anything
because I don't even know what I'm doing.
- Are, are you guys still racing?
- Shut up Matt.
- I got it inked, I got inked.
(Justine groans)
- Everyone is still racing what--
(groaning)
- And by inked I mean I went into myself.
Oh I had a very bad lap.
- I mean, that's why I
don't have a controller.
- I had a very bad lap.
- Do you think it's hard to
play with a half controller?
- No, only when you go to use items.
Look at the way Link sits in the kart.
- Yeah his knees are all pressed up.
- That's like the Squatch mobile.
- Oh gosh, I've been
trying to get rid of that.
Does somebody want it, do
you want my Squatch mobile?
- Matt has room in his belt.
- I planned it I'm swimming, I'm swimming.
- Alright, well I'm in fourth
that I'm just swimming my way.
- What the Hell, somebody already go that
far ahead and dropped bananas?
- Me, I shot 'em forward.
- I'm playing a special game where I--
- Oh that's how it works I forgot.
- Turning the controller
does fine tune turning.
- Really?
- Oh.
- Yeah, and that might
have been why I was--
- So finely tuned?
- So finely tuned into eight place.
- Computer princess.
- Computer Princess?
That sounds like a nice screen name.
- I am getting so unlucky.
- Well I'm in ninth,
so I'm basically last.
- He like, stole my wallet.
(chuckles)
- He stole your wallet.
- He's so mean to me.
I just go inked and
fell off that big jump.
- Wait till he unleashes it.
- Why did everyone just pass me up?
I don't have my sand tires on.
- I didn't even know
there's an eleventh place
until I got into it just now.
(chuckles)
- I need my sand tires.
Mommy, are you still racin'?
- Finally.
- Let the final scores tally up.
- 17 times.
- Wait me and you are tied.
- Oh shoot.
- I need you--
- Going into the last race.
- I need you to not post
this video on YouTube
because I feel like people
are gonna to start calling me
and telling me how bad I am at Mario Kart.
- Ed.
- Don't answer.
- I saw that video.
- Well.
- Don't answer, you're playing
with half a controller.
- Everyone be quiet, it's
down to this, me and Justine.
- I'm gonna come and beat
you guys, bo countdown.
I came in ninth so I'm basically
just fighting for my reputation.
- Yeah I can just turn the controllers.
- I was wondering if I have that too.
- This is like driving in Los Angeles.
I like to, throw things out the window.
- What?
- I'm just kidding.
I have no idea what I'm
even saying, I'm delusional.
- Who did it?
- I think the computer.
- Don't give him the--
- Don't give him the stick.
- Give him the stick,
don't give him the stick.
- Don't give him the stick.
- Hey kid, I'm a computer.
- Alright well, I just accidentally--
- Help computer.
- Stop all the--
- Well that's cold-hearted.
- I'm super slow with my little kart.
Oh my god I just spun out.
Because I am so oh geeze.
The stick.
- Oh wow it didn't give me the jump.
- Aw I'm sorry.
(Justine groans)
Are you guys still racing?
- Nice one.
- I'm sweaty, I'm sweaty, I'm sweaty.
- Shoot.
- I gave him the stick.
- This is gonna propel me
all the way up to last place.
- Aw nice Jenna.
- Aw guys I didn't win.
- I did horrible.
- Why did you speed past the leader board?
In which it showed me winning?
- I wanted to go as quick as I could.
- Did you PB?
- Except in the race.
(Justine groans)
- Alright guys well that's the Grand Prix
that we just played now
let's play some battle.
How about it?
- Bat-tle.
- Let's look at Matt win.
- Hello last place, nice to meet you.
- Are we ready?
To come and get it na na na na.
- Oh you can switch your
steering right here.
- Wait, you can switch
your steering into what?
- See if I press the Y button or
the sideways B button on mine.
- Oo Urchin Underpass,
should we do that one?
- Yep.
- Oo, it's like a
wait a minute
- Splitoons.
- Yeah, oh my god, everyone
is gonna get splatted.
Splat.
- Splat splat.
- We're Splitoonin?
- Don't go backwards Jenna.
Good girl. Splat.
- Oh wow.
- Oh my god I almost splatted myself.
- Remember how good I was
at battle mode at the--
- No I don't remember.
- But do you remember I was also good?
So I would like to make
sure you all remember.
- As long as we both remember
that we were both good.
- We both were good.
- But do you remember when I was good.
- Shoot who did that to me?
- Me.
- Me. It was me.
- It was me.
- I had fire balls.
- Oh.
- What did you have?
- Fire, shells.
- Aw I got split splat.
- Split splat.
- Oo how many balloons do y'all got left?
- Five.
- Oh, I seem to have
lost two in my mission.
- I'm not doing well.
- Well if I lose again then
I think that I am the loser.
- Yep, I just took somebody out.
Wario it looked like.
- I just don't seem to know the map.
- Wow was that perfect timing.
- Wow that was me trying to get you too.
- Well how about you go get someone else?
- I'll get you.
Alright I'll go for Luigi next.
- No that's me, I'm uige.
- Alright, then I'll go for Luigi.
- That's me.
- His brother, Luigi.
Oh no banana.
- Huh, whoa whoa oh no.
- Wait a minute how did I lose one?
- Oh my god, wait can I steal balloons?
- You can.
- How did you just steal my balloon?
- Do you have a black
one? Oh yeah you can.
- Did you just steal mine?
- Look how many balloons you've got.
There all different people's balloons.
You stole one from me.
- Yeah but how?
- How do you steal them?
- I think you do like a crash
into them and it takes them.
- Because someone just crashed
into me and I lost a balloon.
- Me, I've got a crown on.
- Yeah that's how I lost it.
- Well I don't like this game anymore.
- Aw I just wrecked my (mumbles).
I just wrecked my vocabulary.
- Wait you came back?
- You get three balloons on your second.
- So wait so--
- And then it tells you how
many you earned I think.
- Huh.
- I'm super confused.
- Who's dated Luigi?
- Oh boy oh boy Toad.
- Who's Toad?
- Wait what happened I'm Toad.
- Yeah, and you've got six points.
- We could do that.
- It's a little late now.
- Let's do Lunar Colony.
- We're already deep inside
the belly of the beast.
- This looks like a Star Wars map.
- It's Lunar Colony.
- What I've gathered, is that
there's other people in here.
(laughing)
- Yep.
- And it took me that long to realize.
- Forensics degree.
- Loving my degree.
- I only like saw you guys.
- Open your eyes.
- Loving intelligence.
- Yeah you guys are blind.
- That's a tiny screen.
I've only got like at
least 32 inches to look at.
(chuckling)
- You alright there?
- No, I'm not.
- Well I want to go for you guys.
- Stop that.
- I am Link.
- Okay well Bowser hit
me, so Bowser's hit me.
- I'm just sending off green
shells as fast as I can.
- Me too, going after.
- Oh wait what's this feather do?
- You jump.
- What?
- Yeah, its like a big jump for escaping.
- What a dumb power-up.
- Oh no that's incredible.
- Alright wait so how do
you take the balloons?
Does that keep going?
- Oh I hit a banana.
(phone dings)
- I have a crown.
- I think if you really ram into somebody,
it takes their balloon.
- What does the feather do?
- It makes you jump.
- Oh duh.
- Sorry Matty you didn't like that noise,
I didn't like it either.
- Peach, eat my bleach.
(Justine gasps)
- Well I seem to not be--
- Aw crap, I'm not doin' so hot.
- What am I gonna wanna speed up for?
- Oh I found a pile of boulders.
- Toad get wrecked.
- That was mean.
- That's what I was shootin' for.
- There's no root.
- There's no direction.
- Everyone's going the other way.
- I'm going the other way.
- Well then turn around and go get him.
- Oo I want to go here.
- See I'm a do a youie.
- Who keeps hitting me?
- Is it friends?
Is it foe?
Is it the computer?
- Oh my god I just ran
into World War Three.
- I don't know I have a crown too.
- You just took it from me then.
- Oh no I'm dead.
- Oh me too I got dead.
- Aw they take your balloons back
and then they put you back in the game.
- I thought I was dead.
- I'm not very good at Battle.
- Battle.
Honestly I'm just like
hoping that someone...
Wait I sidelined you.
Somethin' just happened.
- Oh I did so bad.
- I made fifth place.
- Oh shoot what happened, we
didn't even get the score.
- Doin' items is actually kinda--
- Who won?
- You did you crushed, you got 12 kills.
- Wow, let's play Sweet Sweet Kingdom.
- I'm gonna sweet--
- I hate this color of happiness.
- I love pastels.
- All I see is black.
(game pings)
- Real into the pastels.
- Is that what these are called pastels?
- Yeah.
- Well I've got green
shells and I'm off punting.
- Matt you didn't know what pastels were?
- Nah I don't know much.
- All I know is breathing and fine dining.
- Breathing?
- [Justine and Jenna] Wait fine dining?
- Yeah you might wanna change your bio.
- Oh I got dry bones.
- Well apparently none of
you guys have ever seen
Sponge Bob Square Pants
- No.
so I guess that reference went
right over you guys' heads.
- That means you're old, all of you.
- He knows Sponge Bob.
- Sponge Bob has been around for 20 years.
- He does not know pastel colors.
- Sponge Bob had not been around
for 20 years because I saw
the premier of Sponge Bob
Square Pants and I'm 24.
- Yeah well if you relate
to something it doesn't
mean it just started when you saw it.
- Yes it does.
- The premier?
- I remember, I remember the premier.
- You went to the premier?
- The premier?
- No the first episode ever aired.
All I did was watch Nickelodeon
as a kid, I had no friends.
- I died, oh, man I didn't do well.
(groaning)
- Oh gosh, ah, I just killed myself.
- I'm not sure are you gonna be happy?
- You gonna bring me back?
- Yeah what am I gonna do?
- More ballons balls.
- Hang out with Matt more?
- I'm gonna be real happy. (laughing)
- Matt'll be like check out this
cool pastel jacket I just got.
- That part where I put the
three shells right in the wall.
- I finish.
- Finish.
- Wait.
- Goose egg.
- Did I win and I died twice?
- I'm not very good at battle.
- Oh gosh.
- I died twice.
- Look at the.
- Who got 17?
- Me.
- Justine.
- And I
(mumbling)
I think I'm good at, I
think U'm good at batt-le.
- Batt-le.
- When did Sponge Bob
Square Pants premiere?
May 1st, 1999.
I said I was maybe
- I was ten.
nine or ten, I was actually seven.
- So you were wrong and
she was closer cause
you were three years off,
she was two years off.
- Three? No.
- I said 20 years ago.
- She said 20 years ago
so she's two years off,
you said you were nine,
you were six, you were three years off.
- Oh wise.
- I won.
- Good job.
- Okay let's play one
more, one more, one more.
- Oh wow you can.
- Computer, no com.
- No com.
- Oh yeah okay what should we play?
Which one do we want?
- Is it we're playing
with everyone or just us?
- Just us four.
- We did Battle Stadium.
We didn't do Dragon Palace, Luigi Mansion.
- Let's do dragon Palace.
(game chiming)
- Let's go.
- Yup.
(upbeat music)
- Alight.
- In success.
- In success?
- Matty you can't go back
there, my body is there.
- Oh wow there's a map, I
didn't know there was a map.
- There's a map?
- Yeah look in the middle.
- Has that been here the whole time?
- I thought that was an outlet.
- I'm gonna do one continuous
drift in the center.
(gasps)
- Gold sparks the entire
time, and when I unleash it
I'm only unleashing it for the next racer.
- I'm just gonna send off green shells for
everyone to deal with eventually.
- That's what I was doing Ed.
- Boom.
- My controller's messed up again.
- Anyone who's been watching my screen,
scrub back and watch my amazingness.
- Anyone that's been watching mine,
don't bother I'm awful.
- Awful.
- I'm behind somebody.
- One continuation.
- Shy Guy.
(controller clicking)
- Shy away from that.
- Get away from me, yeah
see I unleashed my drift.
- Is the door gonna open?
- Aw this door better open dudes.
- Can you go like that?
- Aw you drive right through it, nice.
(laughing)
- Wow.
- I was like, why isn't the door opening?
Did you get my balloon?
- I did and I got kinged.
- Oh my gosh.
I got king business for it too.
(chuckling)
- Shy guy.
I'm getting snubbed.
- Where's Shy Guy at?
- King Shy Guy.
Oh no banana.
- That was my banana.
(gasping)
- I avoided that.
(cheering)
- Another one boy If you don't I'm snakin.
- I haven't killed anyone yet.
(high pitched mocking)
- Me Either.
- I threw out some green shells, have fun.
- Deal with the
repercussions of my actions.
- Oh yeah, I'm outside, you guys
are all stuck inside being dumbos.
- Yeah I haven't actually
gotten any points.
- Well I went outside
and ya'll went inside.
- I'm going outside now.
- I need to find a person.
(whining)
- Well I have boomerang doom.
- I have zero, see Jenn has one.
- I do?
- Are you Luigi?
- Yeah it must be recent though.
- Matt's peeking at the map.
- Yeah no map.
- Oh I'm sorry I'm using the
resources to my advantage.
Of which the game is supplying to me.
- Who wants this flicker,
flicker flame baby?
- I'm doing absolutely awful.
- Trash.
- Maybe I should just stop this video.
(laughing)
- I'm getting my butt kicked.
- Oh I did terrible.
(game chiming)
- Ed's gonna win.
- Shoot Toad.
- C-G Ed.
- Oh snap.
- We tied.
- Great game.
- Awfulness.
(uplifting music)
- Trash. I'm sweating.
- Alight well I guess that's it.
- Alight guys thanks so much for watching.
- Thank you.
- If you enjoy Mario Kart thumbs up.
Okay bye.
(laughing)
That's all I've got. See ya.
(electronic music)